ich glaube dass beiden gewinnt es ist
allerdings viel knapper als ich gedacht
habe muss ich ehrlich sagen dass das
ergebnis nicht überrascht hat ich hätte
mit einem klaren sieg gerechnet aber es
zeigt also wie also gespalten das land
ist und lasse mich besonders überrascht
hat für nur 5 prozent der traum wähler
war die krone krise wahl entscheiden das
muss man sich überlegen was das bedeutet
ja es sieht doch sehr danach aus dass
erstens die wahlen völlig korrekt
gelaufen sind und zum zweiten dass in
der tat die wähler in den usa so
entscheiden wie sie es für richtig
halten ich hoffe auf jeden fall dass es
so ausgeht dass am ende keine krise für
dieses land daraus entsteht dass die
spaltung nicht weiter vorangetrieben
wird und dass ein ergebnis herauskommt
dass am ende so klar ist dass man eben
auf dieser grundlage arbeiten und sich
alle dahinter versammeln können wir
sollten uns darauf konzentrieren unsere
hausaufgaben zu machen unsere
verantwortung in der transatlantischen
partnerschaft wahrzunehmen und nicht zu
spekulieren oder zu bewerten wenn andere
wählen also wenn man tatsächlich
gewinnen würde was ich nicht glaube ich
glaube er verliert aber wenn er gewinnen
würde das wäre für uns also sehr
schlecht
ist jemand der sich alten allen gegnern
recht wenn er also gewonnen hat recht
dass ich an den gegnern dazu würde hier
auch deutschland gehören na ja also ich
meine wir dürfen uns auch bei joe biden
keine illusionen machen dass wir
in die zeit sozusagen vor donald trump
zu bekommen oder vielleicht sogar in die
zeit vor obama eines ist klar wir
europäer müssen uns endlich zu einer
eigenen position auf augenhöhe mit den
usa zusammen raufen
ich sehe da nur die bundeskanzlerin und
dem französischen präsidenten balkone
das tun kann
stichwort handel umgang mit china da hat
trump wie einem punkt da hat er nicht
unrecht und das darf eben nicht nur in
sonntagsreden passieren dass muss zb bei
der einhaltung des zwei prozent ziert in
der nato auch gelten
wir müssen ganz klar für freihandel
eintreten und dürfen da auch gegenüber
china zum beispiel nicht naiv sein wir
sind bild und wir liefert dir deine news
auf youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren